all right thank you all for
for waiting uh we've had some technical
difficulties here
um it's it's my pleasure to introduce
our next speaker ashish kokarni
um his presentation is going to be on
stimuli responsive nanomaterials for
imaging immunotherapy
response he's an assistant professor in
the department of chemical engineering
at the university of
massachusetts amherst and he has
courtesy appointments in the departments
of
chemistry and biomedical engineering uh
and he was recently selected as one of
the top 12 rising researchers
by acs's chemical and engineering
news so i will
move on to his presentation now
good afternoon i would like to thank the
organizers for giving me this
opportunity
to share our work here today our lab
works on addressing
two important challenges in cancer
immunotherapy the first one
is can we design nanoscale approaches to
target
immune separation specifically targeting
immune suppressive cells
in the tumor micro environment with the
hope that we can relieve immune
suppression
activate them in response that can lead
to significant tumor regulation
or anti-tumor effect and the second one
is can we design
imaging probes that can allow us to
monitor
the immunotherapy response early on so
today i am going to share our recent
work on designing imaging nanoprobes
that can indeed
allow us to monitor the immunotherapy
response early on
to go one step further we have shown
that we can not only sensitively monitor
the immunotherapy response
but we can also differentiate between
sensitive tumors
and non responsive tumors and non
responsibilities
but before going to that i would like to
talk about some of the challenges that
are there
in monitoring immunotherapy response and
how we are addressing those challenges
now as you all know immunotherapy has
had and continue to have
a significant impact on on
cancer patients immunotherapy had had
dramatic
uh responses in volatile different types
of aggressive tumors
hard to treat tubers so this has had a
dramatic impact on
how on different types of cancer
patients
indeed if you pick up any leading
journal or a magazine
they have considered immunotherapy as a
breakthrough
something that has a potential to cure
cancer
now considering this excitement there
are several clinical trials that are
currently being conducted this is in
2018
uh the number of clinical trials you see
either as a monotherapy
or in combination with current therapies
and
um ctl for which is one of the immune
checkpoint
inhibitor has more clinical trials
going on than combined chemotherapy and
radiotherapy
so there is a significant excitement
there are a lot of clinical trials that
are going on
and despite this initial excitement
there are several challenges that were
identified
that hampers the successful use of
cancer immunotherapy
in in clinics one of the biggest
challenge
is that this immunotherapy treatments
show low response rate
for example pembroke's limbaugh
antipedia
antibody has shown overall responses
around 20 to 30 percent
variety of different types of tumor
quality different types of tumors
now this can have a significant impact
on the quality of life of patients
because these patients are going
through this uh treatments without a
guarantee of response
without knowing this this will help or
not and
you know they have to go through
unnecessary toxicities of these
treatments if they are not going to help
the tumors there is additional
complication
in immunotherapy is that it does not
follow
conventional research criteria now
racist criteria which is response
uh evaluation criteria in solid tumors
these are guidelines that were developed
in order to evaluate
if cancer therapies are working or not
and to get an
idea about disease progression versus
overall response
now immunotherapy treatments does not
follow this conventional criteria
because it has additional patterns of
immune responses that were never
observed in any other treatments
just to give an idea about what those
responses are um
you know there could be an initial
response which shows that
the treatment is working which are
because of which there's a regression
the tumor volume
or there could be a stable disease where
the tumor volume remains same even after
several several therapy treatments or
there could be a disease progression
where the tumor keeps growing even after
several
cycles of therapies now in case of
chemotherapy radiation therapy
the responses that were shown where
either there is a initial response where
there is a tumor volume regression
or there's a disease progression that
happens uh you know even after several
cycles of therapies
so this is you know easier for using the
racist criteria where you either have a
initial response where the patient is
responding or not or
the disease progression where the
patient is not responding
in immunotherapy there's an additional
uh response that has been shown
where when the when the immunotherapy
starts working
it activates the immune cells and this
activated immune cells
then input it into the tumors this
talking of
immune cells bulks the tumor up and the
bulking of the tumor
you know can be easily misconstrued as
disease progression
indeed currently there are no imaging
techniques
that can differentiate between this is
progression and pseudo progression this
can have a significant impact for the
patients
who are actually responding but can be
misclassified as this is progression and
there's a chance that
the treatment might be stopped where
they actually need more treatments in
order to go
from pseudoprogression all the way to
tumor regression
but just to give an idea about some of
these responses that were observed in
clinical trials
this is null hub which is an antipedia
and antibody
and there as you can see there are
different types of responses that are
observed
where there's an initial response or
there is a stabilization of the
of the tumor as you can see in several
times or there's an initial increase in
the response followed by a regression
that
happened um and you know this this has
been shown
to happen in various different types of
you know immunotherapies as well
and to understand and to incorporate
these responses
in in the assessment in the resist
criteria there were modified
guidelines that were developed so uh
this this called resist 1.1
now i know this is a busy slide but i
want to point
your attention to one of the initial
response patterns where
there's an increase in tumor volume
which is considered
as a progression or unconfirmed
progression in this case the patient is
given
the treatment whether the disease is
progressing or not which means that
if there is a disease progression or
pseudo progression the patient
is uh you know continue to give the
treatment till it is identified that
the tumor is going down at a later time
and this can have a significant
significant impact as i mentioned the
patients are going through this
treatment for longer period of time
without the promise of the response and
having toxic effects because of this
treatment
so we wanted to think about can we
design
imaging systems that can allow us to
get a response at much early uh much
earlier
as compared to morphological changes
that happen at a later time point
and to understand that we wanted to see
how does immune response work
so just give given highlight about image
of the response cycle there are
different steps
uh major steps in immunotherapy response
cycle
now release of cancer antigens happens
because of chemotherapy radiation
therapy
or targeted therapy these antigens
because of the immunological cell that
these antigens are then captured by
antigen presenting cells which are
circulating
uh once they are taken up the antigen
presenting cells then
measure them and present this antigens
once the traffic to the lymph node
to that knife t cells and this t cells
then get primed and activated
and this activated t cells then traffic
uh through the blood vessels
to the tumors and once they go inside
the tumors
then they can recognize the cancer these
cells are presenting those antigens
and once they know that they are binding
to the target cell
then they can release um molecules that
can kill the target cell
right so killing of the cancerous
happens and there are several types of
therapies that are currently being
investigated
are already approved that target
different that activates or targets
different pathways in the
in the immunotherapy response cycle now
there are also
several types of assays or techniques
that have been developed in order to
monitor the response at different stages
one of the most prominent being
identifying the t
cells that are there either circulating
or in the tumor
and you know some of these acids are
listed here i'm not going to go through
all all the acids here but just to
highlight
uh some of the challenges with this
this acids have high degree of
variability they are often
non-reproducible which makes it
difficult
to kind of use this as a basis for
response
where the patient is responding or not
responding
as i said the immune response is in a
complex there are multiple types of
immune cells that are involved in
inducing the immune response so just
finding out one type of cell
or understanding a you know the the kind
of
response from one type of cell might be
too simplified and you know the immune
response is very complicated and
it's very difficult to kind of get a
complete picture
of the immune response by just
understanding one type of cell
you know most of the assays generally
try to
try to get uh the t cells that are
circulating
but the systemic immune response could
be very different than what happens at
the tissue level and in the tumor
uh so you know and and in this you know
if you want to
design an acid where you can get tumor
samples it's
only available for tumors that are
accessible
right so having systemic response does
not mean that the tumors are responding
and even if you get the tumor samples
through biopsies
that are only accessible there only can
be done to accessible tumors so
these are what are different types of
challenges that are observed in
these element response assays there are
biomarkers that could be identified that
can
predict the response but there are no
clear biomarkers that
have shown validity in the clinics that
can be used
as as a way to get a prediction of the
response
imaging assets have been developed for
example imaging techniques
such as mri uh one of the challenges
mri as i mentioned is pseudo progression
right you're measuring
the the morphological gross
morphological changes that happens
once once the methyl treatment are given
this could be
easily misclassified as a disease
progression so
discarded anatomical changes makes it
very hard
to to differentiate between pseudo
progression and disease progression
or responses responsive versus
non-responsive tumors
or tumors that responds late
fdg pain can be used and widely used for
monitoring response patterns
but in case of immunotherapy this can
have an uh
have you know impact because the immune
cells that are infiltrating in the tumor
are you know need glucose for their
activity and this can give a lot of
false positives
same issues it can give you know if the
tumors are responding it
can be easily mis classified as a
disease progression so
this uh imaging techniques lack the
sensitivity and specificity
in monitoring the response indeed
in our studies we have shown that just
measuring anatomical changes
takes longer time and this is in my
studies as as
as we have seen here that it takes much
longer time to to get
a significant response same is the case
with paid city we
you know we see that it takes longer
time in order to understand
if the tumors are responding or not and
you know
having having this uh having this
limitations where sensitivity and
selectivity uh
is one of the challenge in monitoring
immunity response so we wanted to kind
of
step back and see what is it that we can
do in order
what are the what are the um what is the
step that we can
uh monitor the immune response which
happens at
much earlier time point than
morphological rose morphological or
anatomical changes
and that can be used as a direct readout
of immune
very response so you want to say can we
use killing of
the cancer t cells or monitoring of t
cells killing the cancer cells in the
tumor microenvironment
as a way to monitor the response early
on as a way to
directly monitor the response uh earlier
this has several advantages first thing
is that we are not
you know we can we are measuring tissue
level response which means that it will
be very
representative of what happens in the
tumor now we are measuring
that the t cells are actually binding
and killing the cancer cells which means
that this is a direct readout
of these cells not only infiltrating the
tumors but actually
actively killing the tumor cells and
since as i said this is a tissue
response
this can be you know much much different
than what happens at the at the
circulation at the systemic level and
you know even though you have activated
pieces that are circulating that does
not mean that the t
cells will persist for a longer period
of time or go in the tumor
immune suppressor tumor and keep that
activity right so we have a lot of
t cells that might be circulating that
are active against the tumor cells
but they might go into the tumor
immunosuppressant tumor and lose their
activity
or or they might not be able to
infiltrate in the tumor at much higher
concentration so
you know monitoring this uh
that happens when t cells are binding to
the tumor cells and actively killing
the tumor cells would be a direct way of
measuring the response
in real time so we wanted to design
imaging probes
that can not only allow us to deliver
the immunotherapy drug to the tumor
specifically tumor at much higher
concentration
but can actually tell us in real time
whether the treatment is working or not
in order to understand how can we design
the systems we wanted to step back and
see
uh how do t cells kill target cells in
this case tumor cells
so cytosine these cells when they are
once they are bound to the tumor cells
i didn't once they uh identify
the antigen and bind to the antigen they
can kill the target cells by two
different mechanism
one is general side uh exocytosis
pathway glandular
exercise is pathway which is ganza and
perforin society cells can release
granzyme
and perforin uh the granzyme is an
enzyme that can activate gas phases
performance is a poor forming uh protein
that can
uh you know let the enzymes uh
get into the cancer cells and then this
um
granzan b can then activate the caspases
and then lead to apoptosis
or uh it could it can be a death
receptor that receptor ligand pathway
which again activates the cache space 3
and 7.
so we wanted to think about uh about
imaging probes that can allow us to
monitor these interactions monitor
this this type of um changes that
physiological changes that happens
when thyroxide t cell is actively
killing the tumor cells
so one of the things that we designed
was imaging probes that can allow us to
monitor
uh the caspase-3 levels uh that would be
a direct readout of tumor cells dying
because of the
sardocyte cells after t cell after
immunotherapy treatment
or design imaging probes that can
monitor
the granzyme levels in the tumor cells
as a way of
um as a way of monitoring the immune
response
so today i'm going to talk about our
recent work on designing
granzyme imaging probes that were used
to monitor the response
and immunotherapy responsive as well as
non-responsive
so the design was um we use a polymeric
backbone
which has multiple functional groups
that can be either conjugated
that have been conjugated to an
immunotherapy drug and an activatable
imaging initiation
this activatable imaging agent has a
granzan b
substrate and an imaging agent which is
in
off condition but when there is an
immune response this ganza and b
can clear off the substrates and
activate the imaging agent
which can be used as a direct readout of
immunotherapy direct rudolph
of t-cell killing the tumor cells
whereas if there are
no there's no immune response there will
not be an uh release of activated guns
and b
and it will not act with the imaging
agent and we'll see that the
tumors are not responding uh and we call
this granzan bin nano
repo nano reporters or grb gnr
so we designed uh this uh granzambi nano
reporters
by using a polymer backbone that was
conjugated with
carboxybag amine with polyethylene
glycol
uh amine and granzyme pro which has a
die and a quencher and a dye they are in
close proximity so the dye is in a
quench state which means that the signal
would be r
and we uh once we uh incubate this in in
uh in optimized concentration we get a
polymer construct
and then we can uh sonicate this in an
aqueous solution to form a
self-assembled
uh with with the regulated um
uh regulated regulated group on the
surface that can be conjugated with
antipedial one antibody any antibody in
that case but we have conjugated
antibiotic antibody as a proof of
concept
and you know once we have this we have
characterized it for the size stability
uh the functional groups are the amount
of antibodies that was conjugated
and whether it binds to the the cells or
not that binds to pdl when we're
expressing cells or not and then we try
does it actually
induce a response uh in in a co-culture
assay with t cells and
and cancer cells so we have used b16 ova
which is very widely used cancer cell
that expresses oi antigen
and b16 f10 as a control cell uh
all or low responsive cells and we have
ot1 t
cells that binds to the antigen on the
tumor cells and we have shown here that
when we treat it
with the gnr's using
b16 over as well as other cells we get
much higher activation of the granzyme b
reporter as compared to
the b16 cells and we have also optimized
the ratio of
our t-cells to cancer cells and as you
can see here
we see a much higher and specific
response in b16
f10 over such as compared to b16f10
cells so we we know that is very
specific it's very sensitive the
question was can we
now use this probe to to monitor the
response in vivo so
same as as i said we have designed uh
this was
using the the ue the uv range
fluorescent effect pairs we also
designed using
near-infrared uh pairs which can be used
for live mice imaging
and we have designed a probe where that
can be uh injected into the mice
where the idea was for highly responsive
tumors
when there's an activation of immune
response it will
lead to release of the glands and be the
grandson we can clear up this
substrate that will activate the dye and
you can use that as
a direct way of monitoring the response
where the tumors will
light up if there's an immune response
whereas in poorly responsive tumors
we will not we will you know we
hope that it does not activate the
immune response and will not have
activation of the dye and you know and
say that the tumors are responding
because the signal will be in off
condition
now to understand that we designed a
tumor
system where in the right flank we had a
highly responsive tumor which is mc38
because mc38 has been shown
to to have um shown to
respond to immunotherapy at you know
in a highly responsive manner whereas b6
and f10 even though
it responds the response has been shown
to be very poor compared to mc38 so we
had
on left flank b16 f10 and on right flank
mc38
and we also used igg isotope control
systems that can allow us to monitor the
response
and and control as a control
and when we use uh when you use alpha p
delanger you can see here that we see a
response
as the time goes we see a higher
activation in the
highly responsive tumors as compared to
lower as compared to poorly responsive
tumors
and control uh igg uh
gnr's do not really show any activation
as you can see here we have
significant activation of the signal in
the tumor
is a higher tumor to normal tissue ratio
and
and the highly responsive tumors as
compared to poorly responsive tumors
and this is when we injected alpha pdl-1
uh gnr's
it should be generous here sorry and
then we have and this
you know interestingly we see that
there's not much tumor volume changes
that happens which means that
we have used much lower doses uh to kind
of see whether can we use
lower doses to monitor the response
early on
as compared to much earlier than any
morphological changes that that could
happen so
indeed we have shown that we can not
only distinguish between highly
responsive and poorly responsive tumors
at muscular concentration we get a
response
much earlier than uh morphological
changes that could happen in the tumor
and to validate this we uh did ex you
know xx we were acids where
we isolated the tumors after 48 hours of
the
of the treatment and you see that tumors
lights up
in in mc38 and these are three m
tumors whereas b6 and f10 tumors don't
show as much response and you can see
when we
quantify the uh the fluorescence mc3 had
much
higher signal as compared to v16 f10 and
this
correlates with higher grand zombie
expression in
pdl-1 gnrs as compared to igg or vehicle
has much higher serial expression uh in
the pedialone generals again
in case of mc38 which is highly
responsive tumor
as compared to b16 f10 and we see that
there is a higher level of granzyme b
and cleared caspase in the in the tumors
in this case in the pdl-1 tumors
as compared to um as compared to
non-responsive tumors or even imperial
tumors as compared to
the the vehicle or or
control igg nano particles control igg
jnr next we wanted to see can we
actually use it
can we increase the doses of the systems
in order to
see if we can hire it can higher doses
lead to better response
so we use b6 and f10 but in this case we
used three times more doses
that then were done in the previous
trial as you can see here
when you increase the doses you see that
there's an improvement in the response
that was observed even in poorly
responsive tumors
as you can see here that we see as the
time goes we see
a much much higher response and and
in the pdl one gnr's as compared to igg
jnr's and you can see the response much
higher
as compared to control igg again here we
do not see that even at higher doses
there's not much changes in the tumor
volume
but this is again an earlier time point
we see that we can see a response
as early as 24 to 48 hours where the
tumor volume
uh even in seven days we do not see a
significant changes in the given volume
again this means that we can use
activatable systems
uh to to monitor the response much much
earlier time point
than gross morphological changes without
having any toxicities again
we have evaluated this by uh by
monitoring
uh the activity of uh cd cd t cells in
the tumors
branson b levels um that
the cancer cell death uh you know and
also understanding that having uh higher
ground than big correlates with higher
response higher caspase level correlates
with
higher response as well so the first
time we have shown that we can design
this activatable imaging probes that can
allow us to
monitor the response in real time
distinguish between highly responsive
versus poorly responsive tumors
and this you know this response
imaging can happen at much earlier time
point than
morphological changes and if you
increase the doses we can also
see the response in poorly responsive
tumors
and we have recently uh this paper has
recently been accepted in science
advances
so with that i would like to um conclude
that we have designed
imaging probes that can allow us to
monitor the immunity response
early on and even though this is proof
of concept study where we have used
fluorescent-based systems we are
currently working on designing
uh imaging probes that can allow us to
use clinically validated systems that
can be used for
our clinical translation and you know
hoping to have some exciting data
in next year or two with that i would
like to
um thank all the amazing students we
have done
all the work so today's work was mostly
done by anne
anujan anthony and and the pika and
um undergraduate students technicians
and projects in my lab and
my collaborators who have for example
barbara and leonid have
helped me in some of the transgenic
assets that we have shown
and the funding agencies are uh for
their support and for trusting in our
work
and i would like to thank you all for
listening and i'll be happy to answer
any questions
all right thank you she's for that
presentation um we're going to move on
to the
q a portions and it looks like we're
having a little bit of technical
difficulties here with the sheesh's
camera um
[Laughter]
um so we've got a few questions coming
up
strange um one second i'm not sure why
my camera is off
okay all right can you all see me now
i don't think so but i guess we should
probably move on to the questions
um so we've got a couple good ones here
uh
was there any toxicity uh observed um
and that's a great question i mean you
know that's something that we want to
extensively
analyze right before we go to the next
step of clinical translation is to
understand
uh what are the toxicities that are
there for either short-term or long-term
toxicities and
uh you know for for this studies uh for
the
um for the doses that we studied we did
not see any toxicities at least we did
not see any liver and spleen toxicities
but again there is we are working on
doing extensive analysis of all the
toxicities that is required
but that's a great question
could this imaging platform work uh on
other types of immunotherapies such as
uh
car t cell therapy um yeah i mean that's
a great question you know one of the
i mean in this proof of concept studies
we have uh done it with immune
checkpoint inhibitors which is easy to
do because they are
antibodies that can be easily conjugated
for car t cell therapies is a little bit
tricky just because we want to make sure
that we have
uh you know the the spatial temporal
dynamics is a little bit something that
we need to optimize
in order to get the capture the
sensitivity and selectivity right that
is different for
different immunotherapies uh so we are
working on designing and obviously this
platform can be used for
monitoring response for car t cell
therapies and then we are currently
working on
uh designing the probes that can be
adapted for cartesian therapies and see
how we can use those for
monitoring the response for those type
of therapies as well
all right thank you so uh i'm gonna ask
one more question until i get the signal
we've gotta um go off the air here um
what is the size of the assembled probes
and could that affect the tumor
penetration of the reporter
uh that's a great question and that's
been one of the one of the
talk of the nanomedicine field or
imaging probes that are in the nanoscale
is what is the optimum size
and how much do you get in the tumor
right and that's always going to be
important to increase sensitivity as
well
um so the size that we saw was around
100 nanometers which is optimized
100 to 100 200 nanometers which is kind
of
shown to be an optimal size for a better
tumor accumulation
but again we are working on uh and we
have done some initial studies to see
do we actually get better tumor
penetration or not
and we indeed see that we get enhanced
tumor penetration compared to
any of the free systems but
you know we are working on systems that
can allow us to get a little bit smaller
size as well
but without compromising the size the
stability
as well as accumulation and have the
enough amount of drops we are working on
optimizing some of those parameters
fine-tuning those
to to kind of enhance the efficacy but
that's a good question
there's another question that just came
in um talking about
t-cell therapy is highly selective and
is your system more suitable for a
certain type of cancer or tumor
for for t cell therapies now we are
thinking about uh immune checkpoint
inhibitors right and the question that
comes
is uh how do you know if this immune
checkpoint inhibitor will work in the
patients or not
so thinking about uh clinical scenario
we
you know ended for any type of
immunotherapies there is a
a you know side test or diagnostic test
uh which is kind of
uprooted by fda that uh that kind of i
i you know analyzes if there is a higher
pd1 or pdl1 expression or not
and is there a likelihood of patient
responding to those i think that would
be a better way to go about is to see
which type of tumors are most likely to
respond if they are going to respond
at all but you know that that test you
know might not
be very very uh effective or selective
because there are some tumors that did
not have
uh pdl when expression responded so i
think you know
there is some work that needs to be done
in order to figure out what would be the
the best tumors or what would the best
suitable systems to try with
but you know the for proof of concepts
we went with tumors that shown efficacy
in the mice model
for clinical uh studies we will
basically you know we'll work with the
system that can give us an idea about
what expression levels are there
and then choose those immunotherapies
all right well thank you very much i
think we're running out of time
so uh i think you'll have an opportunity
to follow up with some of the
the remaining questions so thank you
again
for the presentation and thank you all
for participating thank you so much